When solving the equation, we want to multiply these terms, and then combine
like terms on the same sides of the equation. Negative 4 times x is negative 4x,
and negative 4 times negative 4 is positive 16. This is one of the most common
mistakes in algebra, forgetting to multiply a negative by another negative when
distributing. Be careful with that. Next we combine like terms, so, negative 4x
positive 2x make negative 2x. Here I'm going to try and keep my variable
positive. I'm going to add 6x to both sides. Adding 6x to both sides leaves me
with 8 equals 4x plus 16. Subtracting 16 from both sides gives me negative 8
equals 4x. And then my last step is just to divide by the coefficient, or the
number in front of the variable, which is 4. This leaves me with x equals
negative 2. Great work if you got negative 2.